so the election and the Member of  Parliament for Nottingham East on  Thursday the 8th of June 2017 I in Korea  being the acting returning officer and  the above election do hereby give notice  that the number of votes recorded for  each candidate at the said election is  as follows Bishop David Lawrence Elvis  and the Yeti Himalayan preservation 195  [Applause]  kotiga Katarina the green party 698  Paul karma Robert guy Michael UK  Independence Party 817 holiday berry  Ian Liberal Democrats 1003 Lesley  Christopher Michael labor and  cooperative party 28,000 102  [Applause]  Marie Simon Peregrine guav a  Conservative Party candidate eight  thousand five hundred and twelve  the number of ballot papers rejected was  114 the turnout was 64% and I do hereby  declare that Christopher Michael Leslie  is duly elected to the Member of  Parliament for Nottingham East  [Applause]  you